so there's a new study which finds that
legalizing cannabis also known as
marijuana pot weed
etc
legalizing cannabis lowers demand for
prescription drugs
and this really shouldn't come as a
surprise to us i mean if we want to
focus in just narrowly on this we know
that sometimes
uh cannabis can be a substitute for
pharmaceutical uh anxiety medication we
can know that cannabis we know that
cannabis is sometimes a workable
substitute for big pharma sleep
medication we know that cannabis can be
a replacement for opiate
pain medication there's a long list and
it's not the idea that cannabis is this
panacea cure-all substance but we know
from good studies
that in many cases
you can find a cannabis-based
alternative for a variety of different
symptoms where you might reach for some
other kind of medication now whether we
say it's better to reach for the
cannabis or not i'm not even evaluating
that in this segment it actually doesn't
matter for our purposes but the point is
we know that there is this very
um the the tentacles
of opposition to cannabis legalization
come from a number of different areas
and now we have a new study which points
very specifically to this aspect of it
there's a good piece in the hill about
this legalizing marijuana lowers demand
for prescription drugs study fines the
reductions in drug utilization that we
find could lead
could lead to significant cost savings
for state medicaid programs the results
also indicate an opportunity to reduce
the harm that can come with the
dangerous side effects associated with
some prescription drugs one researcher
said i encourage you to read about the
study and the details about the study
but as i pointed out they found a
decline in the volume of prescriptions
targeting pain depression anxiety sleep
psychosis and seizures in states that
have legalized recreational use so what
are the kind of important takeaways as
we think about this as a political issue
it makes a lot of sense that lots of
different elements would want to keep
cannabis illegal or at least not
recreationally legal
it increases profits
in a number of different areas i'm only
going to mention a few there's probably
more so big pharma if you have
widespread recreational cannabis
legalization
big pharma profits would likely go down
in those places private prisons we've
said before you know private prisons are
not as big in the united states as some
people think i think the last uh
study i saw says private prison inmates
are nine or eleven percent
of federal inmates
and like
zero percent or close to zero at the
state level i believe that that's true
but to some degree
when you have more reasons why someone
might be imprisoned that's good for
private prison profits for sure
the bail bonds industry
if you take something that's currently
against the law
and you make it legal fewer people will
demand the service of bail bonds
lawyers right i mean to some degree if
you eliminate a crime you eliminate the
need for lawyers to defend people
against charges for that crime
we also know that cannabis legalization
lowers demand for alcohol
i don't know but i wonder if it reduces
the demand for cigarettes maybe i don't
know enough about the cigarette piece to
be able to say for sure and i'm sure
that i'm missing many here uh in my
discussion of this so
this is both why on the one hand a lot
of these different industries would want
to keep cannabis illegal oh sorry i
forgot a major one
police departments
seizures both of drugs but also of cash
associated with the dealing of cannabis
etc that's also another big aspect of
this uh police departments local police
departments receiving significant monies
as a result of cannabis not being
recreationally legal or even
decriminalized at all so on the one hand
you that's why big pharma
would oppose cannabis legalization but
at the same time
it seems big pharma realizes that the
writing is sort of on the wall and big
pharma has also been pursuing patents
related to cannabis so it's like they
don't like it until they take over the
business and can monetize it at which
point they really like it none of this
should surprise us and if you've been
following the political discussion
around cannabis for any period of time
or for more than a decade as we have on
the show you would um understand
the
incongruency and we could really call it
a double standard or hypocrisy that
exists compared to so many different
things when you look at the schedule one
federal designation of cannabis
up there with the most damaging and
addicting substances of no medicinal
value when hold on a second we we know i
mean the study
big pharma concedes
that legal cannabis is a threat to their
profits because it is of medicinal value
without calling it a panacea of course
uh you know that the schedule one
designation doesn't make any sense
uh and we talked about all of these
aspects before so here is another one
and i still on this you know there was a
period i remember early in the show's
history
where we started to see
gay marriage legalization in one state
in another state in a third state in a
fourth state
and at the time i remember conversations
with the team and with guests
there was a certain feeling of
inevitability
that it's hard to imagine 10 years down
the line
that gay couples lesbian couples
wouldn't be able to get married anywhere
in the united states and indeed
ultimately it happened i have a similar
feeling of inevitability to some degree
when it comes to cannabis i don't know
how soon we're going to see recreational
legalization nationally i don't know
about that
but there's a sense of inevitability
that we are heading in the direction at
least of federal decriminalization i
don't know when it will come
but there's that same sort of sense that
i have
if you disagree
let me know i'd be interested in hearing
from you